[Applause]
i wonder
if belichick held him back if this like
strict patriot way thing he was the
system that he was in
the system maybe it held him back maybe
that the way that he was spending money
that we thought was so brilliant he's
underpaying brady and
really investing in the defense and
cornerbacks and all this kind of [ __ ]
maybe uh obviously the offensive line he
needs often but even you told me that
the buck's offensive line isn't amazing
nope they put more emphasis on it when
they got brady but it's not
a [ __ ] fantastic but you know what
happens when you're an offensive lineman
and you're blocking matters yeah when
you know your quarterback will hit the
spot if he has the opportunity
i'm motivated i'm motivated i trust the
guy behind me
i trust the guy behind me it's easy to
block for brady it's easy to block for
my homes it's not easy to
block for [ __ ] sam darnold yeah i
don't
know what is this guy going to do i'm
looking at ghosts i'm going to
see ghosts exactly who is he saying that
about one belichick it was belichick
code like uh they were playing the
patriots who's playing the patriots
so it's like i'm just saying like when
you're an offensive lineman and you know
every time you bang your head you're
gonna forget your daughter's name
ten years right from now like every time
you bang your head you're like oh i
really like my daughter i'm gonna forget
i just lost the fact i just lost the
fact i lost a piano recital
you know i lost a volleyball game i lost
something every time and
for this guy to [ __ ] throw into some
interceptions [ __ ] him
yep [ __ ] him yep okay i'm telling you
when you're doing that for a super bowl
it's gonna change your daughter's life
yeah when you're gonna get that big
contract extension because of how good
tom brady makes you look don't write it
wrong you make him look good too
but that extra effort means two three
four five million more dollars you might
make on that next contract
isn't that motivation 100 i'm starting
to wonder if the patriot way
and we're going to see over the next
five years maybe over the next decade
if the patriot way actually hurt tom
brady
this is the most motivated belichick
will ever see but to your point we used
to always say tom brady's lucky to have
bill belichick
we didn't often say bill belichick is
lucky to have tom brady he might be a
guy
some coaches just don't really value the
quarterback position and he might have
enough ego to say
i don't need a great quarterback i don't
need to spend all this money on a great
quarterback i will coach up everything
else
and we'll be great he might have lucked
into the greatest quarterback ever in
the sixth round
so he never had to worry about
quarterback and a guy who would take
less money to help the team win
tom brady's a [ __ ] unicorn man all
right pay me less i'll make my money
elsewhere i'll get a million dollar ppp
alone who cares
let's just win i don't give a [ __ ]
belichick might have been super lucky
getting brady because since then
cam newton they just got like at the end
of the off season he was like whatever
we'll plug in anybody
jimmy garoppolo he believed in a ton
maybe he could have made jimmy garoppolo
great
or maybe he was just like nah that's my
guy and i don't really care about a
great quarterback
but it's hard to win without a great
quarterback do you have any question
that tom brady would have been a great
quarterback no matter where he went
no question he would have been great
anywhere anywhere he was great in
michigan
he was he won at michigan but they were
so excited about this hype recruit they
got uh drew henson i think
because my peter his both his parents
went to michigan he went to michigan
fanatic
he knows all the history brady was great
but they were like no we got this hot
recruit we got to start him
and that's how brady basically didn't
get love walking out of michigan but he
was good in michigan he won all the time
and then he locked into something else
and maybe belichick had something to do
with that
but now he's like the most focused got
eaten avocado ice cream whatever the
[ __ ] else said
to not to like age as well as you can
got this whole system
i'm just saying yeah i don't know if you
could say that
belichick held brady back because of the
winds
so it's like you can take aaron rodgers
for example who's [ __ ]
mvp this season and doesn't have the
wins because he didn't have the correct
system
i think he would win less super bowls
without belichick but he would still be
great and he might still be the goat
if aaron rodgers had a belichick we'd be
saying this exact same thing
oh yeah great great point that's the
thing when you win
less it's actually better for your
legacy in a way because
especially as a quarterback because it
seems like you did it all
on your own when you are dominant as a
franchise
in a team-based sport like football
where it appears as if one player
doesn't really have that much
of a of a difference making factor for a
team you
naturally lean into the coaching like
patrick mahomes is doing things that are
so out of this world that you're like
you got to credit him yeah
but also there are people that go andy
reid
andy reed offensive genius he's finding
ways to unearth things that you never
knew
nobody looked at patrick mahomes in
college like this yep right
he was i mean he was highly talented but
not wrong nobody everybody's like yeah
he's super raw some people believe most
people were like
that system texas tech system you just
throw all over the place
it's hard for us to believe because
generally speaking there is not
one person on a football field that's
that dominant no
maybe tom [ __ ] brady is maybe he's so
dominant that he could have taken aaron
rodgers packers to the super bowl and
won
he could have taken the giants of the
super bowl one he could take the chiefs
to the super bowl it didn't matter which
[ __ ] team
maybe he's that good maybe he's so good
that he makes his coach who is mediocre
look like a genius i don't remember the
last time the bucks made the playoffs
and bruce erin's the coach that makes
your team better but only to a point
i just wanted to make one point if we
had no problem
saying that tom brady was a system
quarterback we should have no problem
now
saying that bill belichick is a tom
brady quarterback
tom brady coach bill belichick is a tom
brady coach
you have never proven to be victorious
without tom brady
yes you did great when what's his face
stepped in matt castle
stepped in great for having matt castle
sure still didn't make the playoffs
didn't make the playoffs i could agree
with that but by saying
held him back that's he's saying
statistically brady would have gone nut
he would whatever aaron rodgers
but when i see what he's done with the
buccaneers who were
last year decent no yeah they were fine
they didn't make the pl they weren't
even close to the playoffs
but but it was a shock they were under
performing right yeah oh absolutely yeah
but like they were i don't want to go he
took this team took the [ __ ] jaguars
or some [ __ ] like that like
it's not far off that's the thing he's
not far off i think james just was so
bad
he was he 30 touchdowns and 30
interceptions
was crazy but he wasn't he was just like
very hot and cold he wasn't good
fair enough fair enough all i'm saying
is like if we had no problem removing
credit from tom brady
yeah we should have no problem removing
credit from bill belichick
seeing what they both did without each
other it's not like they don't have the
same salary cap it'd be one thing if all
of a sudden the patriots has
had this salary cap that was reduced by
50 now they don't have tom brady
they both had the same amount of money
to spend this year did they not
i mean if bill belichick can get tom
[ __ ] brady to take less money on
contracts
you can't get some linemen that you
overpaid to do it
like all of a sudden frees up a lot of
money
i mean not so much because he wasn't
like getting crazy right like he was
doing
you're still highly paid quarterback
you're getting a lot of right so
20 million a year still 20 million what
is this bitch-ass excuse that he comes
he was oh we sold out remember when he
said that we sold out this year
like he said we didn't have enough money
essentially to pay it's like what do you
mean now you don't have enough money
now all of a sudden money is an issue
get people to take less money you got it
with tom why can't you get the other
guys to do it you're supposed to be this
brilliant coach you can get people to
buy in
because he had he had the unicorn and
tom brady he had the [ __ ] unicorn i
don't think bill belichick is the unique
one
and i'm gonna go so far to say he's not
winning another ring for the rest of his
career
it would be great to see it would i
don't even know if he'll make the
playoffs in the next
five years that would blow my mind that
i don't see
i don't know if he's gonna get a ring
without brady anymore but now the thing
is with someone like bill belichick i
actually have
like empathy for because how does he
know if
he's a genius or not you know what i
mean
yeah like because he's calling plays and
then the plays work and he goes
yeah tom did a great job with that but
also i called to play and
and he's a defensive g like he breaks
quarterbacks like broke sam darnold
he broke jared goff a little bit i think
jared goff
nobody like the rams were so good sean
mcgay was so good and in that super bowl
he told his defense here's what happens
with this team the quarterback has a
headset for the rams
they go to the line with one call they
look at the formation and before
communication with the coach gets cut
off
he the coach reads the defense and says
this is the play you're going with
bill belichick was like all right we
have two defenses we have one defense
that we show them
and then as soon as the call comes in we
switch to another defense right which is
[ __ ] amazing right so he defensively
can break you
like just but you can't win without good
quarterbacks but does he
just can't to his credit though he might
not know if he's a genius or not
you know no i understand what he's
saying it's like when things
are successful you're gonna assume that
you play some part in that yeah you take
over a company and you're the ceo and
the
company's doing amazing like you're like
am i a genius or did i just happen to be
in
the have the best product or whatever in
my company you know what i mean it's
hard to not take credit for success
especially when you are you know when
the buck stops with you
when your name's on the plaque like
after 20 years of doing this you must be
like
you're telling tom what play yeah now
granted every coach who calls a play if
the play is successful will take
credit for that play being successful
but you still need players to execute
said play but i completely understand
him having an ego there's no question
whatsoever
i wonder how big that ego has dropped
or how much that ego has dropped this
year yeah it'll take a couple years for
it to set in
but you know what's interesting is he
got success pretty quickly and the best
thing that happened to the chiefs might
be andy reid not having success
with the eagles now he goes to chiefs
and he has this amazing quarterback
andrew reed will never think this is me
i did this he thinks i played a big part
in this
but i know who who the [ __ ] unicorn
is here and it's this guy right here and
so there's not going to be
an ego battle right mahomes seems like a
great guy but like there's just
reid is never going to be like you're
nothing without me so so sorry about
sorry but how about this
andy reid yeah way better coach than
bill belichick
and i'll say this just for this reason
andy reid
has taken quarterbacks that were not
that good yep
and made them incredibly successful
within his offense
right we've seen that with donovan
mcnabb
nick foles alex smith alex smith and
michael vick oh that's right michael
vick
was not a very successful pass first no
quarterback and then andy reid turned
him into a quite successful pass first
quarterback there's no question that
mike always had an arm and all that kind
of stuff but he actually
i think i i don't think that i'm better
overextended
everyone better right bill belichick
gets cam newton
who isn't the same cam newton he was
right but
is coming off a lot of down time to get
let his body recover
and it's not like he's forgotten how to
throw a football it's not like i mean
can you get that much worse at throwing
a football
no as long as you're not injured yeah he
made him worse cam newton became a
worse football player under bill
belichick
fact or fiction well he at least
couldn't fix him if he was broken he's
still broken
you didn't make him better michael vick
was broken and then goes to andy reid
and all of a sudden yeah this is a deep
threat well he's always a detroit but
but this is a guy who could carry your
[ __ ] team he went to the playoffs out
of prison
that's the guy out of prison you always
say if you take time off from football
yes you can't come back it's over it's
too fast of a game now
vic is a freak freak out complete yes
andy reid definitely helps
i know another freak athlete cameron
newton oh
you're right i'm just saying you make
this quarterback who is maybe a shell of
himself that's fair
but worse undeniably worse under you
you don't make quarterbacks better as
far as we've seen
again matt castle is right the exception
but didn't matt play
somewhere else with the colts or
something and do decently i think he
went to the chiefs afterward and i think
he sucked
okay fair enough he's always bad after
that there was another oh maybe it was
uh
prescott played with the cult remember
they had another
jacobian
all i'm just saying is like if we're
willing to light up
tom brady for years and say he's a
system quarterback he's not that good
and say
all this [ __ ] belichick needs some smoke
too if we're gonna have these
hypotheticals you're not wrong
i mean if why why are people defending
him if we're gonna have hypotheticals
let's have some real hypotheticals
came with the [ __ ] goat this
guy out here looking pathetic
he's making quarterbacks stink you know
he's a quarterback
killer as far as i'm concerned given
this past season
you don't want if you're a quarterback
you do not want to pay for bill
belichick this guy will kill you
bro he yo he gonna get you murdered he's
gonna care about
bro if you're at a quarterback and
you're at a point in your career where
it's teetering
nobody's picking up cam newton in the
last he ended cameroon's career
playing for bill belichick yeah ended
cam newton's football career
maybe maybe a backup yeah there's not a
question in my mind that if cam newton
played for andy reid
he needs a contract next year yo you
absolutely right and we all thought cam
newton going to the
patriots was like no bro they're back
they figured a way they're back they
always do this but belichick's not good
enough he's not yeah
belichick's not good enough he's not a
good enough coach to extract
talent from a player what i'm trying to
say is imagine tom brady had a real
coach
that could actually make him better sean
payton andy reed sean payne and andy
reed
imagine he had a real [ __ ] coach that
improved
their quarterback this is a no-brainer
what tom brady would i think more rings
i think belichick
held tom brady back i mean can we just
look at belichick's record like i'm
trying to find [ __ ]
losing record without tom brady but like
he is a defensive genius
but that's only happening but like
because tom brady's been playing
football for what 20 years
yeah he came in and got belichick a ring
in his first year that's what i'm saying
we could see tom brady's record easily
but like belichick has existed without
tom from tom brady buried a mediocre
coach
to the promises he carried a mediocre
coach to the promised land
and then without that mediocre coach
that overrated mediocre coach yeah
and his mud in the attitude he was
allowed to have a curmudgeony attitude
we're doubling down here we go
he was imagine imagine being a
mediocre coach that is hanging on for
dear life
hanging on to tom brady for dear life
like his first baby mama
hanging on right you megan moynihan
asked
him moynihan ass coach okay
what was it csi i think law and order
one of them
right hanging on for dear [ __ ] life
being rude to the media wearing a stupid
cut off [ __ ] sweatshirt
you know that [ __ ] was genius oh look
yeah he doesn't even care about what he
wears
oh you won't care now you're going to be
nice and buttoned up you're going to be
answering some [ __ ] questions going
into cam newton's closet now
100 100 all i'm trying to say is
we gave a lot of credit where it was not
due yeah tom brady could maybe have 10
rings right now if it wasn't for bill
belichick
easily maybe 20 [ __ ] buccaneers what
was the last time
the last time the buccaneers won a super
bowl or even went to the super bowl
warren
sapp was on that team they haven't won a
playoff game since they won the super
bowl
[ __ ] you know how great tom brady is
he's been to more super bowls than every
other team in the league
including the patriots unbelievable wow
unfucking believable he's so
funny if the super bowl if he has a
whole game like he played in the second
half
he might but he got there you're gonna
have to eat all right he got the hurts
and and what's his face didn't even get
no no he got i think him getting there
it already solidifies everything he
doesn't need to win if he does win we
need a new word that's not goat
yeah no other quarterback joe montana
went to the chiefs actually after he
got traded from the niners and they
wanted steve young he went to the
championship game great
lost brett favre with the vikings
championship lost
super bowl never been done and he's
older than all of them
43 years old imagine he was 37 and did
this
imagine tom was young oh and did this
forget it there's no second half like
that i mean the fact that
bill belichick was underpaying him
to ride on his [ __ ] coattails yeah
it's a travis it's a travesty
but that's what
this is interesting
you